aussi loin que mes souvenirs remontent
j'ai toujours eu un profond sentiment de
fierté pour mon pays
ces pays la france que nous avons au
coeur donne envie de faire avancer il ya
une vraie volonté collective de changer
la donne pour la france s'engage et
c'est croire en la france c'est croire
en la république
nous avons créé des républicains pour
vous donner l'opportunité de vous
engager
pourquoi l'engagement utile si parce
qu'on peut changer les choses parce
qu'on doit changer les choses
l'engagement est quelque chose de
fondamental particulièrement pour les
jeunes pour défendre notre idéal commun
qui est la république à travers ses
valeurs liberté égalité fraternité mais
également la laïcité et le mérite mon
engagement au sein des républicains il
est pour moi une évidence parce que
seuls les républicains et ma famille
politique sont capables aujourd'hui de
défendre un projet ambitieux pour notre
pays je suis maire d'une commune de
45000 habitants en bourgogne et cet
ancrage local
il amène nécessairement réfléchir sur
des thématiques nationales les maires
sont en pointe pour le combat pour la
défense des idées sur le territoire et
sur le terrain au plus proche des gens
je ne sais pas
porter l'idée que la politique peut
encore agir sur notre destin que la
politique aujourd'hui ça a encore du
sens les républicains c'est la famille
de toutes celles et tous ceux qui ne se
résignent pas si la politique nouveau
semble pas assez
si les projets que nous défendons ne
sont pas assez proches de zhouqu
l'occupation alors saisissez
l'opportunité vous engager on a besoin
de vos idées de vos énergies de votre
talent alors engagez vous rejoignez nous
pour changer les choses il faut les
changer de l'intérieur
devenez acteur du changement avec nous
avec les républicains
et